this entire film takes place on a train
but not one day was spent on an actual
train what gives buckle in for a wild
ride as we go through all the movie
magic that brought bullet train to life
number one
brad pitt did about 90 to 95 of his own
stunts and he just won't be tamed man
according to his director david leach
brad is an incredible athlete and
obviously one of the biggest movie stars
working today and that's because of his
work ethic and talent and checking out
this behind the scenes footage it shows
number two
real flames on set no big deal joey king
handled working with small pyrotechnics
like a boss because on this set they did
not hold back when it came to filming
dangerous scenes practically
number three
there was definitely blood you know when
you sign up for a david leech movie you
know you gotta get a couple battle scars
you know some war wounds aaron taylor
johnson wound up leaving the set with a
pretty nasty one and we're not surprised
why after hearing this
get drop kicked across the room and the
one sharp bit of the corner basically
but it wasn't any padding well that
sounds awful
took a chunk out of my hand and uh and i
literally went warm passed out number
four
well sort of
and it was in the heart of lockdown so
uh
we're not we're not going to tokyo even
though they really really wanted to the
pandemic was not letting up so they had
to bring japan to them ninety percent of
the movie was actually filmed on a
soundstage sets like the highly detailed
subway made the movie feel like they
really were in japan but while they
didn't leave the country they did still
hit the road sometimes
number five
epic seems like the right word to
describe it some of the crew who would
get motion sickness okay well that isn't
so cute but the fact that the set they
built was that convincing is impressive
they created the you know great train
and then platform in the studio the
platforms were all made to be modular so
the crew could easily adapt and change
up the set to look like multiple
different cars we had several train cars
three train cars that they could redress
and swap around but our favorite part
these video walls this was what was so
amazing these they were like 20 feet
tall and football field long okay so
they weren't exactly that big but they
were massive and the video walls were
responsible for playing footage of
rushing scenery outside the train window
they really did bring japan to them
they'd be flashing the trip from tokyo
to kyoto number six
what did you say
this freaky and weirdly cute mascot was
based on an anime character but why was
momomon included in the movie it was to
show some of the wild sights you can see
on a train in japan since there is an
actual pokemon themed car on a real
bullet train cool as it is honestly we
wouldn't want to share a train with this
character it's great
yay number seven yeah this one is brutal
brad you know the consummate
professional he is decided during part
of the choreography to go wouldn't it be
good brad pitt could get a bit caught up
in the moment if i just hit brian in the
nuts over and over again and did maybe
go a bit too far at times
number eight
it's not an action comedy without some
laughs although these ones weren't
always appreciated it's a shock they
made this movie at all knowing how much
joking around happened on set we were
just trying to make each other break and
crack this was partially because david
leach gave us so much room to like
improv and ad-lib so
who was the most fun to make break on
set the best would be getting the camera
men who are like literally trying to
hold the thing together or the boom guy
number nine
this doesn't sound easy
and surprise surprise it wasn't for
david leach the toughest stunt to pull
off visually and technically was when
the guys were flying out of the door
since according to leech we had to have
stuntmen on a wire three riggers and
polar
unfortunately the set posed a problem
since the plan was to kick the guys out
the door but it wouldn't really work out
for that so they got creative number 10
the work never stops being able to adapt
quickly really worked in their favor
director david leach pushed his team
making the stunt team work late and
re-rigging the set just so they could
create a fight and film it quickly how
quickly well leech admitted that
we just did it on the fly and we leaned
in and we got it teamwork always makes
that dream work
number 11.
he knows how to dress
he surprised us with his stellar outfit
choice at the premiere for bullet train
but we had no idea brad pitt was the one
to credit for this wacky yet iconic look
in the movie his director did say
brad came in on fire for big and broad
which is why he opted for the thick
glasses and bucket hat
we don't hate it
number 12
would we expect anything less yeah he
trained a lot while he didn't spend
months preparing he did put in the work
even while the pandemic made it tricky
early on before we were shooting we were
going to his house masking up like
getting our tests and the proof is in
the pudding and getting him in a
fighting shape those workouts worked
number 13.
pitt knew his place he may be a movie
star but he took a hit on set when he
needed to
literally he just was really gracious
about allowing people to slap him
number 14
they were everywhere you looked
since apparently on a train you've got
to be resourceful when it comes to
fighting this team got as creative as
they could when building the fight
scenes but that's not all they seriously
used anything they could on the train as
a weapon chopsticks tables needles
briefcases laptops
number fifteen
she might punch you in the kisser she
spent three films playing a sweet girl
in a kissing booth but joey king brought
all the tough vibes for this role she
even brought the heat doing a lot of her
own fight sequences
number 16
who was asking none other than the star
of the movies brad pitt a great dialect
coach
so good in fact that it confused some of
her co-stars on set when i was shooting
the movie the days i was working i would
just stay in the accent and brad thought
i was british for the first two weeks
number 17.
what can't david leach do the director
of the film wanted in so bad that he
actually dropped out of directing
another film called the division to do
this one but considering bullet train
has really brought him full circle after
first working with pitt as his stunt
double early on it's no surprise you
know i've been working with brad for so
long supporting him as a stunt double
building characters that bromance is
real now he's going to build this
character that supports me as a
filmmaker number 18
ladybug was one unique character but the
truth is
pitt took a load of inspiration from
physical comedy legends like buster
keaton and jackie chan and those vibes
set the tone for the whole team david
leach tested that pit well he was
leading the way
number 19
it wasn't always an action movie script
in fact bullet train was inspired by a
book from 2010 called maria beetle which
only got its english translation over 10
years later
its author kotaro isaka did say he
thought it would be an ideal hollywood
movie
number 20 pals can make some great teams
this film was partially a success
because of the close relationships
between many of the main people on the
team the film's producer kelly mccormick
happens to be married to the director
david leach who as we know happened to
be brad pitt's stuntman for much of his
career oh and the editor of the movie
elizabeth she's edited almost every
movie the couple have made together
and there you have it this blockbuster
blew us out of the water and to know
they had such a blast making it well
that just makes us love it even more
which impromptu weapon used was your
favorite